Oh wait. You have
something in your eye.
Oh no.
It’s just sparkle.
Aaaah!!!!
Welcome to Charm Battle,
bitches.
I’m sorry if I’m been
following you all night.
My parents always told
me to follow my dreams.
I’m not an organ donor,
But I’d be happy to give
you my heart.
I’ll give you a solid 18.
Mira mamacita...
Oooh!
You can’t do that.
I think you’re suffering from
a lack of vitamin me.
Just because you
were bilingual,
I’ll give you a 54.
Hey yo Ma,
I like your jersey.
Can I have you
name and number?
If you were a fruit,
you’d be a fine-apple.
That was so gross.
Can I give like negative
7 points for that?
I’m new in town,
Can I have the directions
to your heart?
I’m gonna give that a 3.
Lightning round!
Are you Netflix?
Because I could watch
you for hours.
Let’s commit the
perfect crime,
I’ll steal your heart,
and you’ll steal mine.
4 + 4 = 8
But you + me = fate.
Are you from Starbucks?
Because I like you a-latte.
If you were a flower,
You’d be a damn-delion.
My name isn't Julio,
but you tryin’ to
get to know me?
Ok guys...
I have a winner.
The winner is...
Aaahhhh!!!!!
I can’t compete with this.
There’s a winner
in all of us.